we're talking about things like world
economic forum paying attention to stuff
like climate change
and they're going to use a crisis
to exact more control over you right
controlling your finances monitoring
your finances your spending habits where
you go what you do
and them having access to all these
things is going to be part and parcel of
that
so let's say it's the year 2030 and you
decide to it's uh march
let's call it 28th let's say it's close
to the end of the month right
they're probably gonna have monthly
quotas under the guise of oh you know
carbon credits or the baby seals are all
dying the icebergs are melting and uh
you know the polar bears have nowhere to
swim or to catch their seals sort of
thing
and then you're gonna all of a sudden
have a limitation on the amount of
mileage that you can put on your car
and if you've exceeded the mileage you
can't use your car so it's march 28th uh
of the year 2030 and you want to go to
the grocery store to get some get some
groceries and some food and your car
won't run because you've exceeded your
carbon credits okay so now you hop on
your bicycle and you ride to the store
or you walk to it because everything's
within close proximity you know that's
how people that's how they're
encouraging people live
so you get the store you get all your
stuff it's in the buggy you go to the
checkout thing
and uh
you know she scans your steak
and she goes oh sorry i can't sell this
to you because you've exceeded your
carbon credits you can't you know you
can't have this meat right now you're
gonna have to wait till you reset next
month
so they take the steak away from you and
they hand you a bag of crickets or bugs
or some [ __ ] like that that are supposed
to substitute protein maybe it's a big
bag of soy right
that's the way things are potentially
going to go and they're going to argue
because of
climate change they're going to argue
because of the next pandemic they're
going to argue because of i don't know
russian hack or whatever it happens to
be that they need access to all this
information so this is why we're taking
away your paper money and giving you the
digital currency this is why these
safety features are in your car not so
you know the world will get destroyed or
in case somebody steals a car and we
want to shut it down or we have an o.j
simpson you know scenario where we don't
endanger the park
public we want to shut it down
so these are some of the things that i'm
starting to see
you know
on the horizon if you know what i'm
saying
it is definitely coming down the road at
some point ace of diamonds uh says thank
you for changing my life doing the work
lost 35 kilograms that's a lot of weight
dude awesome read your book rollo's
loving it keep up good work thanks man
appreciate it
uh
tommy's in the house saying there was a
fantastic argument for globalism and
elite control by integrating many
backward countries in the 20th century
much harder argument today see the thing
being with the whole like
most people are going to buy into this
and you can tell by the way
human beings vote right now it's the
reason why
canada is essentially a lockdown state
because
canadians have voted for liberalism they
voted for justin trudeau the new
democrat party both of these two parties
control the majority of the house of
commons in any making whatsoever
which also you know conveniently tie
into more free shed and handouts and
just stay home like there's actually
people right now that i'm that i'm
hearing talk publicly on social media
because it's free and they broadcast
their [ __ ] all the time i mean if you
want to learn more about the mentally
deranged we used to lock them up in
insane asylums back in the day now they
have a tick tock account they go make
these [ __ ] [ __ ] videos all day
long talking about how
awesome stuff is
or you know complaining about how they
don't like certain things but um yeah
like you get the idea um it's it's it's
it's certainly going in such a way that
your
your peers
your neighbors you know the people in
your country especially in the west are
voting for bigger government with more
control
it's certainly happening canada not so
much in the us again i mean the good
thing about the us
you guys are one of the most armed
countries in the world and that should
never change
um that is an important like it is it
was
it was brilliance on the foresight of
whoever wrote that constitution i'm not
that familiar with american history you
know the forefathers whatever they were
called that was brilliant you know for
them to include that amendment into it
where the public had the right to bear
arms um justin trudeau by the way at any
opportunity that he's had available to
him here in canada has taken that right
away from canadians that are lawful uh
you know law-abiding you know citizens
that acquire their firearms for hunting
for the protection of
um you know
farmstead on their property deal with
varmint stuff like that
but
um i think it was
2016 or so there was there was a uh a
shooting out in the east coast where
some guy
illegally acquired a uh police uniform a
police cruiser
now i don't know exactly how good these
replicas were or if they were you know
the identical ones and illegally
acquired firearms and he used that um
tragedy in fact to enact new law to take
away canadians firearms access to buy
stuff like that he's banned certain
firearms you know as a result of that
and it's like all these crimes you know
are committed by pieces of [ __ ] but then
the people that are law abiding are the
ones that are paying for it and he's
using that argument to strip canadians
away from the right to bear arms so
there's all these small little things
that happen you know i've always said
look you know
people go oh well you don't know what
you're talking about or you know you're
drawing conclusions blah blah blah
really because if it walks like a duck
it quacks like a duck it has webb's feet
like a duck if it waddles its tail like
a duck
it's probably a duck okay i don't have
to tell you it's a duck i could i could
tell you let me let me describe an
animal for you it's very tall lives in
africa has an extended neck it has polka
dots all over it it's kind of a yellowy
color
and uh its legs are really strange to
the point where it can't bend them so
when it has to drink it has to spread
them apart so far to get its head down
low enough to drink water and you'd be
like that's a giraffe right that's kind
of like what we're doing here you know
we're kind of like picking up the
breadcrumbs and connecting some dots and
seeing what things look like and then
drawing some of those conclusions so
what's the solution to all this
let me pull this down here
uh
i don't know why i left the
unplugged alpha brand on the screen
there take that off my bad so what's the
solution all this
well the pacification of the west is
obviously contributing to it you know i
was having a conversation and
um i didn't make a note to talk about
this but i'm going to talk about it
anyway so
i i did a video on my channel and i
think it's called the pacification of
the west if i'm not mistaken it's old
it's like four years old maybe um maybe
even five years old
um but i saw what was happening at the
time
as it related to men becoming weaker and
weaker and making you know [ __ ]
choices and
you can't control a strong society you
can't control
independent thinking
you you just can't if you want big
government if you want control over your
citizens if you want to enact
restrictions and monitor them
you need sheep
so
government is essentially engineering it
has been engineering sheep over the last
couple of decades that i've noticed
anyway
um
a lot of people have speculated that the
reason why
um
i think it's something like in a recent
survey
it was definitely in the 20 range
something like 25 to 28 percent of young
men and women today
now identify with the um alphabet
pronoun crowd you know the alphabet
brigade
and i think that's up until the age of
33 was the group that they were dealing
with
um
typically in the past
with humans i think the incidence of
um
homosexuality is like very very small
it's like less than five percent or
three percent in the animal kingdom it's
it's it's it's even lower than that
right um it just generally doesn't
happen but now we but now we live in an
environment today where a lot of people
identify with
pronouns and they're unclear on whether
their gender is male or female i mean
today in you know the news media it's
all over twitter today they're talking
about this uh
leah taylor i think is her name used to
be a dude that was um
i think he was ranked something like in
the
it was either the 40s or the 400s as far
as like you know top swimmers you know
top professional swimmers it was abysmal
it wasn't even the top ten so couldn't
compete against
uh biological males
went to go compete against biological
females and destroys them all
and it's what they wanted right you know
they wanted progressivism they wanted
more inclusivity they wanted you know
let's hold hands and sing kumbaya on all
that kind of [ __ ] and take care it's
like you know that's what they wanted
now they're upset at the results that
they're starting to experience okay
so
they've been encouraging this behavior
it's why government mandates
legislations and laws
uh it i mean here in canada jordan
peterson was made famous back in the day
for
speaking out against the compelled
speech on on pronouns he's like no i'm
not going to use pronouns it's that's
stupid for all of these reasons
it's why the the government is mandating
legislation
to facilitate the
pacification of the west because when
the west is pacified fully it votes for
bigger government and more control
because it can't think
um low t i mean
i have a video on my plane to win series
with uh
dr anthony j who wrote the book esther
generation
and this guy's a scientist very well
researched knows exactly what he's
talking about it's a great book again
it's one of the books that i have my
recommended reading list i think all
guys should read it because it gets you
clear on the
[ __ ] that goes on
with how environmental estrogens are
being forced upon us at levels that
we've never seen before in history uh to
quickly recap
um it's in toiletries it's in sunscreens
uh when you drink tap water because they
can't filter out what women take in with
birth control pills and those hormones
and the estrogens they they pee them out
in the toilet they go in the water
system they clean out all the poo and
the toilet paper and all the debris that
ends up in the water like all the
particles you can't filter out hormones
so those hormones then as you open up
your tap and you drink the water end up
back in your system and there's a lot of
men today it's why you see a lot of guys
today walking around with high pitched
voice and man boobs um there's no
there's absolutely no question that the
wes is being pussified hey guys i really
hope that you enjoyed that short clip if
you did consider supporting the creation
of content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational essentials
for health immune health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching i
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out
you